now
what we are going to look at next.
Is an application of the Bayesian?
theorem
How we can use that derivation of conditional probability?
to make an inference
about some
situation
this particular example comes from a very
great.
book that is not exactly a textbook but
It doesn't excellent job of explaining the intuition
not just of bzean inference but statistics.
as a whole
and it's this book.
the art of statistics
learning from data
by David halter
and
just so you know.
the author is
well, it says here he served.
as the president of the royal statistical Society
and has been knighted for his services to statistics. So
you know, this is
a great expert on the topic of statistics
and that particular book describes the
intuition of Bayesian theorem
very well in particular.
When it comes to the different terms that go into
the formula namely odds.
and likelihood
Now, of course we are going to explore.
Bayesian theorem
when it comes to probability distributions, but
let this be our starting point.
Let's see how those terms in the Bayesian theorem.
are used
in a particular
example
so
this example has to do with
some case study or a thousand athletes
have to be tested.
for doping
Right. So in many professional sports
it is illegal for you to take certain.
drugs
or
the the practice of or when
you take a illegal.
Drug substance to improve your
performance or recovery. We call that doping.
So doping is illegal that many professional sports.
And athletes have to be randomly tested to make
sure they don't have any.
illegal substances in their bloodstream
now the tests that is being performed is 95%
accurate.
It is 95% accurate at.
You know.
Saying that someone is in fact doping.
and 95% accurate
to say that they are not doping.
And here we have a thousand athletes.
20 of those athletes are actually doping.
Now, let's say we we know this for a fact.
We know for a fact that they are doping.
And 980 are not.
So they're actually innocent.
So one more time.
We have a thousand athletes 20 of them are actually
doping.
We know this.
Despite the test.
And 900 80 of them are not doping.
We know this for a fact.
Now we want to know.
If this screening test which has 95%
accuracy.
could make
could tell us.
about this fact
that if we were to put
all of these 1,000 athletes through the test.
To what extent would it be correct? Yeah, it
says 95% accurate but
there's actually more to it than what this.
That we then what we're told about the test.
So if it is 95% accurate how many?
How many athletes?
Who are doping cannot classify?
And in fact, that's the question here if the screening test
is performed.
and the athlete tests positive
what is the probability that they are
truly positive?
It could be the case that they
test positive incorrectly. That's what we call a false positive.
So how we are really asking is
How do we know if?
The result of the test is a true positive.
And here's a tree.
That can illustrate.
What we know about this particular problem.
So if you see here, we have 1,000 athletes.
And we set 20 of those 1,000 athletes
are actually doping we know this for we know
this for certain.
We know this with certainty.
And 980 are not doping. We
also know this with certainty.
however, when we perform the screening test
the test manages to identify 19 out
of those 20
athletes
19 out of those 20 doping athletes
one of them tested negative.
So that one person was actually.
Doping they were taking drugs, but the
test failed to detect them.
In practice this can actually happen.
The sporting authorities do have a list
of illegal substances.
But there are ways you can chemically engineer.
the molecules
or the sequence of the drug somehow so that
it evades the test. That's actually a problem,
but it does happen.
So $20 doping 19 hour positive.
One of them is negative. So they're actually doping but
they tested negative.
on the other side
We have 980 athletes who are not doping.
correctly tested negative
but 49
of those athletes
Tested positive.
with this information
We want to get an empirical.
quantity a numerical quantity
That tells us.
How this put how this this test would perform.
given two events where the first event
Is the actual test?
And the second event.
Is the doping.
condition of that athlete
to repeat the question. It says if the screening test is performed
and the athlete tests positive.
What is the probability that they are
truly positive?
If I could rephrase this.
What is the probability that the athlete is guilty given?
The test is positive.
So we have the probability of a given B.
That's the particular question that we want to answer.
Now, how do we come about these numbers? Well, first
of all, how do we get these numbers? Well, this
is let's say we know this.
Maybe they are part of some sort
of clinical study.
We have two.
groups one group we intentionally
Give them drugs the other 90 would
the other 90 and 980 we don't.
And we do this for the purpose of seeing how effective our
screening test is. So we know for a fact
20 people are doping the others are not.
How do we acquire the other numbers?
well
This is how we do it, right?
We know that the test has a 95% accurate
accuracy.
so if you multiply
the accuracy of the test
by the number of people who are actually doping we get
19. So 19 is 95% of
20.
And similarly 931 is
95% of 980. That's
basically we just multiply these two numbers by
95 and then we get these numbers.
Then if we subtract 900 if we subtract
980 from 931 we get 49.
And obviously subtract 20 from 19 we get
one.
And that's how we get the numbers.
Now we know that the test is 95% accurate.
What we do not know.
So we know that it has 95.
It's probability is 0.95.
for testing positive or negative
But that is a modular probability.
We want to know what is the probability?
That they test positive and they are actually guilty. So
we have two events. We are measuring the probability of
one event given another event.
It's not going to be 95%
and let's actually see how we can find out what the actual number is.